[Musique]
chers amis démocrates nous sommes ici au
jardin de la gare sur la commune
nouvelle de Condé Svir dans le
département de la Manche ce lieu nous
l'avons entièrement rénové entièrement
réaménagé ils avaient été pendant trop
longtemps désaffectés et nous avons
décidé d'en faire à la fois un lieu de
renaturation mais également un lieu
d'attractivité avec un ensemble comment
de services qu'on peut offrir à la
population et notamment en terme sportif
en terme de rencontre que ce soit pour
les petits ou pour les grands et de
façon à donner tout son sens à ce projet
nous avons également réalisé une voie
verte qui se trouve derrière moi et qui
permet de relier cet ensemble
réaménager au bord de virire avec
l'installation notamment d'une
passerelle et puis vous aurez remarqué
également que juste derrière moi se
trouve ce bâtiment de l'ancienne gare
que nous avons aussi revalorisé pour
l'association du véoril mais également
pour le centre aéré tout ça fait un
ensemble cohérent pour un investissement
d'environ 1200000 € mais pour un reste à
charge pour la commune de comp sorir
d'environ 30 % du montant
to